Останнім часом деякі користувачі Deutsche Welle Українською
у коментарях пишуть,
що Німеччину буквально заполонили
"орди біженців". І що незабаром
від суто німецького мало що залишиться.
Якщо говорити мовою цифр, то
у розпал кризи біженців восени 2015-го
з-поміж усіх країн ЄС саме в Німеччину
справді приїхало найбільше шукачів притулку.
Але далеко не всі вони залишилися у ФРН.
Згідно зі статистикою Федерального відомства
з питань міграції та біженців, від початку кризи,
тобто за останні два з половиною роки,
клопотання про отримання притулку в Німеччині
подали понад мільйон триста тисяч осіб.
З цих клопотань задовольнили лише трохи більше половини -
772 тисячі, а 440 тисяч -
відхилили.
У цифрах це менше відсотка від
80-мільйонного населення Німеччини. Вже у 2016-му
кількість новоприбулих біженців
суттєво скоротилася - їх стало утричі менше.
Зменшити потік мігрантів вдалося,
по-перше, завдяки угоді ЄС із Туреччиною,
що приймає назад біженців, які дісталися берегів Греції
з турецької території. По-друге,
офіційний Берлін вніс до переліку так званих "безпечних держав"
Чорногорію, Косово, Албанію та Сербію і,
за новими правилами,
громадян цих країн депортують за прискореною процедурою.
Попри гуманітарні міркування, Німеччина, населення якої старіє,
приймаючи біженців, сподівається на певні економічні бонуси,
зокрема для ринку праці.
Від тих, хто отримує статус біжеця, очікують швидкої інтеграції:
їм пропонують мовні курси, курси перекваліфікації,
відвідання шкіл та дитсадків для дітей.
За статистикою Федерального агентства з праці,
станом на перше півріччя 2017 року
в Німеччині працюють понад двісті тисяч біженців.
Офіційний Берлін визнає, криза біженців -
величезний виклик, з яким зіткнулася Німеччина.
Тим не менше нині німці, вочевидь,
схвалюють політику Меркель,
адже її партія має наразі
найкращі шанси на перемогу на виборах 24 вересня.
Та й самих німців тема міграції
хвилює дедалі менше. За останніми опитуваннями,
лише для 25 відсотків ця тема
важлива на виборах. Для порівнняння:
питаннями безпеки або освіти німці переймаються
утричі більше.